[Music]
my gosh look we're having love there's
so many reasons to like uh the shape of
water congratulations I talked to you at
the premiere and I told you I told you
Awards buzz all over all right wait
actually I called this one like two
years ago you know what you did you told
me right right we got Richard my co-star
nominee tonight oh my gosh he doesn't
know me I know I know right he doesn't
recognize me without my fish suit on I
think but I also have to commend you
because Star Trek Discovery has
captivated
oh my god I mean what if what has been
your favorite part of that experience
because for me it's week to week fan
theories in between my Twitter feed has
never been this busy in my ever and the
nine years I've had it but I will say my
favorite part has been the growth of my
characters through over the over this
season going from like scared Cal peon
to now like I have to command a ship
because the captain's have to we're
playing musical captain's chair right
yeah I know so I keep I'm first office
like I have to keep stepping in and
going alright I'm in charge today
and I think I know what I'm doing so
that's been that's been a ride for me
what would you like to see from surreal
going forward if it were up to you I
don't know that he or I am ready to be
captain captain with with the full at
the full badge yet more to learn but I
would love to I would love to I don't
know yeah I want to see us go back to my
homeland and find my family and explore
my backstory and my people where I come
from
[Music]